this is not my studio but this place
reminds me of a guy I used to know and
he used to say he used to say smack it
smack it smack it
we smacked it let's market what does it
mean to smack it
[Music]
and that's how not to smack it let me
tell you a story a story of how I got to
turn just smack it in the urban
dictionary one year from now I guarantee
you that if you smack it every single
day you will far exceed your vision of
success have you ever been in a
situation where you are hesitant about
pursuing something great and your mind
says go brute just do it and you're like
what do you mean just do it that doesn't
sound very convincing but if you only
had a voice that said just smack it you
had got no questions
I used to be a seriously skittish kid
one that didn't commit too much well I
read I'm still skittish now - I just
have a bigger better voice in my head
telling me to smack it to believe in
myself
my friend Casey heard me saying this a
couple of times and eventually decided
to make an entire episode of three six
eight dedicated to the effectiveness of
the stir we were in Highland I was very
sleep-deprived I ended up getting a
tattoo on my shoulder of a sardine that
says what of a sardine when all of a
sudden I had to pull an all-nighter
editing and it was in that moment in
time the Casey looked at me in my eyes
the windows to my soul and said dad just
smack it needless to say I stayed up all
night I ended when the coachman got it
out in the morning and then continued to
smack it before I think about another 60
episodes in the episode after I see this
if you believe in the term let's try and
make it into the rakia wall no no
definitely if enough people want to
smack it with me I start using the word
and eventually it could make it up into
some sort of a like if everyone just
starts smacking at the world would be a
better place a matter of time
you prove who is so awesome to this and
I've got my first ever phrase in the
urban dictionary but what does it really
mean to smack it it's not a film term a
jargon localized area specific
colloquialism it's rather a u-turn and
I'm giving it to you
as a motivator smack it is a final
decision-maker it means I'm going to
enter the situation headfirst no looking
back
never it means that when I told myself
to smack it
I don't think about anything that's
gonna stand away from me achieving what
I've set out to do that day that man
that year I just smacked it you know get
it done Luke yeah come here booth how
long have you been working here for I
think it's been about get a check so new
can i we kind of sit together at night
alone if you don't know Nick he works in
the engine room of three he smacks it
very hard
but that you've been working yeah what
does smack it mean if I tell you I'm
gonna smack it
it's a promise from me to you then
whatever happens I'm gonna finish what I
set out to do before we get to the sign
outs and the sponsors of the film I just
want to show you some bloopers but this
is really funny video to Maggie
enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
do you like my shirt my friends made it
for me that's read it then if you want
to smack it to the next level by
educating yourself you should learn more
about your passions and interests new
year new me kind of thing if you take me
for an example I use skill [ __ ] to push
myself further
and if you don't did know what
Skillshare is brew well Skillshare is an
online community for creators with more
than 25 thousand online courses in
design business and more the Premium
Membership is done as it gives you
unlimited access therefore you can take
any class that's right for your new
year's goals
I really think the classes from some of
my favorite filmmakers Maddy Brown and
Ryan booth I suggest you check those
ones out they are super good oh yeah and
then Skillshare is super affordable for
a year's membership it works out to less
than ten dollars a month
therefore you should join the other
seven million creators that are really
using the skills share the first 500 of
my subscribers that click on the link
below get a two month free trial and
other than that
don't forget your awesome brew and I'll
see you next week probably Thursday
coolest damn shots on stream you only we
can kick it up weekend baby now sleep
[Music]
the sky was falling
[Music]